that is my destiny
because i remember people being not even
so much like
angry like they are like on the internet
where they're just like ah
you know like like railing against
something they just felt like this
yeah a betrayal like you you just caught
your boyfriend in bed with somebody else
like
all of this and this is how you leave me
it was almost depressing
um i don't know mark do you recall that
from that time
i sort of learned from the last jedi
release to call back your point earlier
that
i really tried to not get in the heads
of of
fans and and critics too much as to what
they were expecting but
a lot of me reacting to the reactions of
game of thrones season eight
was based around there's so many people
who love this so much that they actually
read the books and when i say read the
books 90 of them
did the audiobook they listened to it
they had it read to them so
you don't get a mensa membership for
that but they cared about it and then
all of a sudden
hbo and the creators of the show sort of
are going forward from the books because
george rr martin hadn't finished writing
what he was going to do and so i think
that whereas they were approaching the
prior seasons
with some working knowledge of what was
going to happen even though those took
some twists and turns that weren't in
the books
they knew what to expect and then they
just became like the rest of us where
it felt like it was just flying by the
seat of our pants and making this up as
we go along because nobody
really knew how this was going to end
and so i think that left a sour taste in
people's mouth
just my two cents what about you andreas
i mean i'm sure you
were watching it real time did you feel
like left out with how angry people were
did you feel like hey were you like
trying to you know
evangelicalize them that day and be like
no look this is what's good or where you
kind of like i get it
yeah i mean obviously if we remember the
game of thrones was the biggest show
when it was airing it was everyone was
watching it uh i remember my roommate
and i watching it uh ass season eight
was airing and i would watch
i watched a long night with him episode
three and i was just kind of like
ripping out my hair
uh and being blown away by what i was
seeing on screen and after the episode
he was like oh yeah what was that and
i'm like what was that
it was it was a cinematic masterpiece on
tv
uh and we just kind of forgot about it
because we wanted
more answers i guess is the biggest
thing that game of thrones fans wanted
um i also feel like it's a little bit
it's very complex because i really do
feel like the way that game of thrones
fandom just dissipated into nothingness
is something that is just gonna be in
the history books
i've never seen a fandom disappear to
the point that game of thrones fandom
has disappeared
after season eight because if you want
to say star wars for example as far as
fandoms split on the sequels
there's still a lot of sequels fans
there's still a lot of star wars being
made
and there's still a lot of people who
enjoy going back and re-watching those
movies
i i don't know any game of thrones
i don't know game of thrones twitter
game of thrones tick tock
uh the way that there is like other
fandoms who have just come back strong
so there is no denying that the fans did
feel some sort of betrayal
i just feel like there's one major
decision that was made
that kind of got people up in arms and
they just kind of forgot about the other
six hours
of the season that actually was really
well shot
directed performed done acted
uh everything was just quality all the
way but the fact that
my the decision i'm referring to is bran
being king which is
definitely a wtf moment uh everyone was
like bran is king
ah season eight sucks
[Music]